welcome back to new rockstars this is a
big question the show that gives you too
much information about sentient weapons
like
white vision and how we built more
nightmare sword could ever have enough
hangers for
i'm your host with the most that
people are gonna be so upset about i'm
sure jessica clemens here
tommy beck told oh jessica they better
not be upset or i will go to their
houses personally
and murder them you do not roast this
host this is the host with the most
and i would like to propose a toast okay
you can roast me now
because tommy made that right i'm okay
with it oh no
only a select few people hate no nobody
hates you except for
weird internet people and who even knows
if they're real they could be trolls
truly my mom it is just my mom messaging
me on twitter over and over again
telling me to stop
it's very it's really weird because for
me it's my dad and he's just texting me
can you please pay your own cell phone
bill this month
uh that's much nicer my mom says you
could have been a doctor
and i go i don't know i don't like blood
i don't like needles right luckily my
parents have healthy
healthy understanding of my intellect
and knew that being a doctor was never
in the equation
it's never gonna happen no i think you
could be a doctor you could probably be
a good vet
yeah definitely a cat doctor let's get
into a big question you guys do not want
to hear
me and tommy talk about our careers so
in the mcu sword stands for sentient
weapons observation and response
department
and the main sentient weapons that sword
director hayward seems interested in
is the reanimated corpse of vision yes
we're talking white corpse coming
through a white corpse
white vision his secret weapons program
project cataract uses the vision's body
to create white vision
so the question today is what real world
secret weapons program
has the us government unleashed or at
least planned to put into use
there's so many oh there are so
so many so let us make haste
beginning with oh one of my personal
favorites the manhattan project
new york concrete jungles where we
explode you you know the words
well yeah you're from new york of course
you know the app i'm from i'm from the
canadian part of new york though not the
cool part anyway
this is by far the most famous secret
weapons program
from the us that resulted in the
creation of the first nuclear weapons
now see what happens is when a scientist
and another scientist are in love they
can get together to create a diabolical
weapon
capable of destroying entire cities
anyway the name comes from the army
corps of engineers method of naming
projects
after the geographical regions where
they took place the atom research
originated in new york
so the name manhattan project was chosen
this is kind of like how
david beckham and victoria beckham named
their son brooklyn
because he was conceived in brooklyn got
it got it got it
got it i was very confused you gave me
this like
very similar to like my little brother
whose name is denny he was conceived and
born in the denny's my mother carried
him to term
inside one denny's uh anyway manhattan
project uh
it was pretty small in 1939 but by the
end of the project in 1946
it had employed over 130 000 people
and cost nearly 2 billion dollars which
would be 23 billion dollars today
that's a lot of bombs research and
production took place at more than 30
sites across the united states
the united kingdom and canada hey
ah how did they keep this a secret it
was everywhere
people were blabbing like honey you
promise you won't tell
at work today i split an atom it was
pretty dope
uh all right pretty dope i split an atom
workers were told that their work would
help end the war in perhaps
all future wars well and we know that
that turned out to be very true
because after we dropped the bombs on
hiroshima and nagasaki
there was no more war
except for the supermarket wars the war
on christmas thanks libs
and of course my favorite the chocolate
war
delightful book yeah it's a kid's book
oh wait is it really
i can't remember what it's about so
we're gonna just edit this out all right
a 1945 life article estimated that
probably no more than a few dozen men
in the entire country knew the full
meaning of the manhattan project and
perhaps
only a few thousand others even were
aware that work on adams was involved so
there's
hundreds of thousands or at least a
hundred thousand people that went to
work and were like
i don't really know what we do okay so
you just went into work in 1945 not
knowing
and there was no work slack to like
gossip on it's the one division working
in the like
what do we do here and then be like we
gotta just
type papers out exactly
i bet the most people that asked
probably got like they disappeared
if they asked what their job was because
no one can know about this
yeah they're like you'll be testing the
project now
most people involved in the project were
in the dark as to its full scope
workers were warned that disclosing the
project secrets could mean 10 years in
jail
or a 10 000 fine
wowzers workers would often see large
amounts of raw materials come in but not
know what it's for
they would simply record readings on
dials without knowing what the
measurements meant
kind of like lost when they're just
punching in the code no one really knows
why
a 1945 report by the united states army
stated the manhattan project was more
drastically guarded
than any other secret war development no
[ __ ] it's a atomic bomb
sorry about that well that was just a
little cell phone tangent you can note
that out
in the early days of the project in 1943
security
investigators vetted 400 000 potential
employees
and 600 companies that would be involved
in all aspects of the project
for potential security risks i feel like
this is illegal for us to be talking
about
i guess people might know about it if we
if we're talking
about it out loud i'm afraid now once
this video comes out
we're gonna be kidding yeah so let's
remind everyone i am uh eric voss and
this is marina mastros
and we are having a great day oh wait i
thought i was reading about
i thought you were eric boss that makes
more sense because and i am marine corps
yes florida people you all built
different i'm not from florida i'm not
you're not forgotten i'm not from
florida
nothing's wrong with florida just like
tommy said earlier nothing's wrong
with florida nothing wrong with it don't
hold on to either of those two
statements
it's a cursed land though there's
nothing wrong with it but it's a cursed
place yeah and you go there
[Laughter]
anyway at the hq in oak ridge tennessee
hq is short for
his teen slang for headquarters security
was especially tight
private parties in people's homes with
more than seven people were considered
suspicious or as the kids say suss
original residents of the town were
allowed to be buried in the town
but every coffin was inspected first
that's creepy
everyone was searched going in and out
of the facilities uh including top
military brass
okay all the secret work meant morale
was very low no kidding so in oak ridge
the extensive system of intramural
sports teams was created
including 10 baseball teams 81 softball
teams
and 26 football teams that's american
football
not uh not european football i'm sorry
so they distracted people
yeah from there from making bombs with
with like a little
wrecked song yeah i think hydra would
still be around if the red skull had put
a little intramural soccer game going
so if the nuclear weapon i know this is
real this isn't like a
cartoon but if it did give you super
powers wouldn't that be just like super
unfair if you're playing softball
against the team that makes the nuclear
weapons
gone forever i know that all of this is
straight up crazy
but i also feel like if someone somehow
got some nuclear waste on them and
they're about to
literally like pitch someone out those
shouldn't go together
they shouldn't be in the same realm it
should be illegal for you to play after
you've been given superpowers
81 softball teams that's 80 too many
that's 80 too many
uh all right anyway after the hiroshima
and nagasaki bombs were detonated in
a lot of workers were shocked to see
that this was what they had been working
on
though many were still unsure if they
had helped or not i mean that would be
really a crazy experience where you're
like ah honey did you hear they dropped
a bomb on nagasaki
oh they did yeah it was from the
manhattan project
isn't that where you worked i don't
think so
i think i was working on the queen's
project that's a little let alone
they put their initials on the bomb
jeremy stephens their handprint like
it's a cyborg
oh god we're laughing oh at the worst
yeah
this is a realistically horrible time
yeah since this is real it is horrific
but but it is crazy that people did not
know they had this job
they didn't have the job the military
had already prepared a report called
atomic energy for military purposes or
amp no it's not an acronym guys uh two
released
to the public on august 12 1945
explaining the history
of the development of the bomb okay that
was nice of them
i'm sure they were very forthright and
finally in 1946 the united states atomic
energy commission
to establish civilian control over
atomic
development was created so i guess it
it went away from the government went
away or went away from the military and
became a civilian
matter hey okay they just wanted
no one wanted hands in that pot
afterwards they were allowed to get rid
of this as soon as possible
manhattan project that's like the that's
that's the headliner that's like that's
got to be the biggest one that we know
of
manhattan project yeah i feel like
that's a drink also
but again i understand this is real
look i understand this is real history
right um i personally
am very surprised that that many people
didn't know i
i don't i don't want to say that they
didn't know but i feel like
one or two definitely knew and were like
yeah i'm making a nuclear weapon
yeah i mean like anything there were
probably a lot of people that were like
i didn't
know what was going on and they're like
that's why it's the fact in this when
you have two nuclear bombs in your
pockets what are you talking about
i didn't know why are you saying
as they get rid of all their papers
you're the manhattan project you're the
manhattan project
let's move on to another secret
government project
this one is a personal favorite of mine
because i'm a bit of an
animal guy this is the bath bomb aka
project x-ray this is it development why
would you say i'm an animal guy
follow if you know this story anyone go
go i love this story i know this one
developed developed by the us during
world war
ii something about that world war ii
that just brought out the best in us
guys
the bomb had over a thousand
compartments each containing a
hibernating
mexican free-tailed bat with a small
timed incendiary bomb attached
oh wait first of all was the joker in
charge of this
this was the joker in charge of this
project this is straight up some
like him meets mojo jojo and princess
like
all of them combined kind of ludicrous
[ __ ] to do
but we're gonna take these bats and
we're gonna strip bombs onto them
flying over people thinking bats would
even listen so the idea was the plane
would drop the bomb
at dawn when bats are horniest as the
bomb fell a parachute would release
to slow the descent the casing would
then open and release the bats
who would find eaves and addicts to
roost in within a 20 to 40 mile radius a
lot of moving parts here
this is literally what we tried to do
this is something we tried to do we
thought this was a good idea we thought
this was so
brilliant when we came up with it okay
the timers of the small devices
attached to the bats would then go off
setting fire to the mostly wooden and
paper building materials
used in japanese construction at the
time this would create
thousands of fires across the city all
it was this is a batman villain scheme
this is a this is the penguin this is
something i could see
maybe uh raza ghoul doing i mean a lot
of fighters all over the city seems very
league of assassins the league of
shadows sorry
uh the idea for the bat bomb came from a
dental surgeon from pennsylvania
named oswald cobblepot what no named uh
lido ass adams so a dentist a dental
surgeon
came up with bath bomb and the
government was like yeah that sounds
great man we would love to do that
yeah dude kid is a bunch of bats yeah
well here's why he thought uh he thought
it up after a trip to carlsbad where his
parents were both brutally murdered in
front of him after seeing him play
no uh he found it up after a trip to
carlsbad cavern
where he observed the bat's behavior so
he went on a nice trip
with his family presumably saw a bunch
of bats flying around carl's back cavern
and he's like i wonder if we could put
bombs on these little
you guys ever put a bomb on a bat these
bats are beautiful
you know what you know what's a little
more beautiful if we put bombs on their
feet
uh tiny bombs i know the best people
adams was an acquaintance of first lady
eleanor roosevelt never heard staff
friends in high places
and wrote a letter to the white house in
january 1942
a month after pearl harbor and i'll tell
you what in february of 1942 he should
have been arrested
and charged with criminal insanity uh in
the letter
adam said the bat was the lowest form of
animal life ouch
and that until now reasons for its
creation
have remained unexplained wow i mean
first of all
bruce wayne better not hear this or he
is going to be devastated
oh my god are you crying no it's just
raining
i don't want to make like a salacious
accusation but it sounds like a bat bang
this guy's wife
my wife what he is very angry
yeah it's rude to be like this was the
lowest form of animal and he's crying
and i hear they have very small penises
that can't satisfy a woman
we should put bombs on their penises um
and have them fly high as he's crying
take me back i'm so sorry
jesus man so president roosevelt
naturally
approved the idea and of the dental
surgeon adams he said
this man is not a nut which means he
definitely is
it sounds like a perfectly wild idea but
it's worth looking into
just like bombing hurricanes injecting
bleach into your
system and looking directly into an
eclipse this is the these are the people
we elect
president it's bipartisan idiocy let's
just elect a smart person for once okay
let's just elect a bat a bat that
my wife i went to carlsbad cavern and i
saw
a bat flying around and i said he should
be the leader of the free world
you know what i like this guy i could
have a beer with this guy
you know it comes down to who am i gonna
vote for joe biden or a bat to bang my
wife
uh
this is all probably unusable
eric and philip are never gonna let us
do anything on this channel again
well to be fair they once they were like
it's you and tommy i was like oh
it's gonna go off the rails
listen i'm a sinking ship don't don't
let me take you down with you save
yourself if you have to
can't help i love it i'm a yes and i'm
an improviser
you're too good to me the project was
started by the air force
and the team working on it included
hollywood actor tim holt
who appeared in a lot of westerns from
1930 to 1950.
nobody seemed to question the morality
or ecological consequences
of sacrificing a few million bats
everybody was like well if tim holtz
here
that sounds pretty cool that would be
like if nicolas cage did like a secret
weapons project now
well i mean the whole nicholas cage
having a pyramid
ready for his casket is not like the
same as this but it's like
we're like okay with it because it's
nicholas cage yeah we're like yeah of
course
he gets it he gets a pyramid of course
he does and that pyramid gets launched
into space
why is nasa there it's an ancient
egyptian space shuttle
the bats were fitted with small tanks of
napalm glued to their chest
each back could carry its own weight in
napalm 15 grams
and each bat bomb could hold about 1040
bats
that's a kilo of bats uh the testing of
this weapon was
problematic yeah it was rough to test
this one out
in one instance the carlsbad army
airfield auxiliary air base was set on
fire when armed bats
accidentally released and they roosted
under a fuel tank
in what i call karma another
questionable thing i mean we've done a
lot of
questionable ridiculous things as the us
but
this one specifically of just like oh
yeah bats aren't gonna stop flying
they're definitely not gonna be tired oh
gravity works
so after the accidental fire the project
was moved to the navy and given the
badass name
project x-ray then it was moved to the
marines
because they were like great name navy
you're done
the marines carried out a test of
project x-ray on a fake
japanese village they constructed and
found it to be
more effective at starting fires than
the bombs they were currently using
wow so the bat bombs do work uh
but should they no no no
no no no no project x-ray would never be
used in battle as it was overshadowed by
the previously mentioned manhattan
project at the end of the day
about two million dollars was spent on
project x-ray which would equal about
19 million dollars a day only god knows
how many bats were sent to the great bat
beyond by a dental surgeon but needless
to say it was definitely worth it and
i i'm sure that a lot of people were
comfortable having that guy operate on
their mouths after this
[Music]
oh wait yeah let's go back to the fact
that this man's a dentist would they
listen to me
we have a comedian here she's got a
great idea for a bomb
um i think it'd be fun if we had pinatas
and we just like
lured people to them
i bring my own bombs every time i do
five minutes at the comedy store
and then they're like wait this might
work people get so sad they just fall
asleep
this man just bombed harder than
anything i've ever seen god damn get
those
project x-ray out of here we got johnny
petrol in the house
write that down write that down that was
the bat bomb
project x-ray worth every penny in my
opinion uh
oh next one yeah rate your favorite ones
guys in the comments let us know which
diabolical project
is your fave oh next one is fun this
one's got a cute name that our
fans of new rock stars will recognize uh
from what is
and see if you can make the connection
this one is called project thor
this uh the concept of project thor yes
the god of thunder and lightning rhyme
is also called a connect kinetic orbital
strike this idea came about during the
cold war
in the 1950s so we've got a post-world
war ii weapon here
it was also known as rods from god i
swear to god that's what it is
no you don't no you do not no one can
take that name now i'm taking it
i watched a movie called rods from god
once and it was uh
i don't want to hear anything about very
sexual our god
has an awesome rod may he reign
focus thomas strong focus on what i want
essentially project thor is a weapon
system that uses satellites to load in
space
to launch telephones full-sized kinetic
projectiles
made from tungsten from earth's orbit to
damage targets on the ground it uses the
force of the earth's own gravity
to move these giant metal rods at
orbital velocity
impact speeds could reach mach 10. so
basically giant space javelins
the size of telephone poles firing down
from space
if zeus was in track and field
[Music]
we did this evidently we developed it i
don't know if we ever succeeded
it works like a bunker buster some
systems could have the same damage yield
as a small
tactical nuclear bomb tungsten was the
chosen material
due to its heat resistance which makes
sense if it's going to be all the way up
in space
each rod is estimated to cost about 230
million dollars
which is more expensive than just a
regular old bunker buster bomb
okay well that was uh uh very expensive
we are getting so much money well this
we god we love spending money on weapons
don't we
uh sorry to get all political they'll be
like he's a secret liberal yeah actually
usually
usually usually the commenters accuse me
of being secretly a republican
and they're right they're like he's
definitely conservative he sneaks in uh
conservative comments all the time i'm
like
where tell me where i said [ __ ] where
please point them out and i will stop
that right now
find that for me project thor was
originally envisioned by jerry pornell
jerry pornell or jerry porns as his
friends called him while working at
boeing
in the 1950s he would later go on to be
a science fiction writer
well of course i guess that makes sense
aerospace
into science fiction is a natural
progression i think
project thor would be difficult to
defend against with 68 satellites in
place
any target on the globe could be reached
within 12 to 15 minutes
i mean you get some time to run away
[Music]
the rods would also be extremely
difficult to track on radar
and since they are dropped from a moving
satellite and not launched like a
ballistic missile
it is difficult to determine where or
when a release of a rod from god had
occurred
the 1967 outer space treaty prohibited
the us from deploying nuclear
biological or chemical weapons in space
project thor
avoids this agreement since neither of
those things
plus it promises to deliver strikes more
powerful than the many types of nuclear
and chemical attacks without the messy
fallout that follows
the nuclear strikes are you sick and
tired of all that messy fallout
well boy do we have a product for you
it's a god rod everyone
but i want to say the ride from god
let's thank one of our sponsors
rod gods god rods from the makers of
manscape
boy do i have comments for them it's a
messed up stop it
project thor stop it stop it
we're talking about rods from
[Laughter]
is gonna be like never again are we
gonna let these two be on one together
the next time i met him
the next time i match with someone on
bumble and they initiate a conversation
which never happens i'm going to go want
to see my dog rod
and then and then you're like i wonder
why they blocked me
unmatched and you called the police uh
okay i'm always i'm gonna be single
forever project thor was outlined in a
2003 report
from the u.s air force though we have no
official word on the status
of whether or not the rods are up there
right now are you kidding me
it probably is my dude and oh god it's
gonna shoot down one day
no kidding the rod gods are coming in in
june 2020
a senior al qaeda leader was killed by a
kinetic weapon that was dropped
by a u.s predator drone the weapon
reportedly weighed 100 pounds and
contained
six deployed blades to destroy the
passenger vehicle that it was targeted
this type of weapon has shown up in
science fiction since the 1960s
including project thor's creator jerry
pornell's own books
as well as popular shows like babylon 5
and the film starship troopers
oh i love starship troop i love starship
trooper it's a great movie
i love it i love the alien that sucks
the brains like a straw
like a slurpee don't like the rod god
though no the movie
not the rod god the wrong guy that we're
still
kind of using it very troubling that the
rods from god are still up there
uh let's lift things up a little bit
with a cheerful little weapon project
i like to call the heart attack gun in
the 1970s congress became
increasingly worried about president
nixon's abuse of power through the cia
and then watergate happened and nixon
resigned but congress still wanted to
know what was up with old tricky dicks
an investigation into government
agencies by
senator frank church turned up a lot of
shocking abuses of power
by multiple agencies but one weapon
developed by the cia was
particularly shocking the church
commission revealed the cia had
developed a gun capable of firing a
frozen dart
into its intended target the dart would
melt and release a nearly undetectable
poison
that could cause the victim to have a
cardiac episode
mimicking a natural heart attack like an
icicle
yeah like an icicle that makes you have
a heart attack the dart could penetrate
clothing it would only leave a small red
dot on the skin
the toxin could not be detected in an
autopsy the gun itself was a modified
colt 1911
that fired the frozen ice dart using
electricity
an icicle also this is also mad this is
this is crazy this
is american garden
question was actually presented to
congress by the church commission and
the acting cia director confirmed
that it was the gun used to fire the
deadly dart
so we've used this thing in the wake of
the church commission's findings
presidents ford and reagan both issued
executive orders
banning targeted assassinations by the
cia i'm sure that the banning of
assassinations by the cia was really
adhered too i
i'm i'm 100 sure they obeyed that so far
that one was probably my favorite if i
had to use a weapon that would be my
favorite
yeah i mean that one is the most like
spy game
the rest of them are just like we're
gonna devastate you with something truly
evil
project pigeon is next up that's cute
this is i'm sure gonna be very innocent
this was yet another animal-based bomb
program
the us navy worked on during world war
ii why
why do you guys hate flying things so
much what
what what who hurt you did the pigeon
bang your wife
the idea was that the pigeon can be
placed inside the nose cone
of a bomb to act as the guidance system
because bombs at the time were not
incredibly accurate so the pigeons were
trained to recognize and pecked at an
enemy unit
such as a ship when it appeared on the
screen once inside the nose cone
three windows would project an image
onto the screen of the target
the pigeon would peck at the screen keep
the bomb on track if the target started
moving off screen the pigeon would begin
pecking at the direction
the bomb needed to go the sensors would
adjust the trajectory
as needed i mean pretty impressive it
actually worked quite well in simulation
but was never actually put into use
probably because higher-ups were scared
of pigeons
driving their bombs which makes sense by
1944 the project was completely scrapped
the navy did revive the project with
other animals under the name
project or con for organic control in
1948 but scrapped it again in 1953 once
electronic guidance systems became much
more reliable
okay pigeons yes
what in what world and what world iphone
pigeon iphone which
one lovable person that loves you cold
lifeless
metal i don't understand
terrifying uh but yeah there's some
examples of some government
secret weapon projects that are real i
really
slept on pigeons it's never too late to
turn around your opinions on a pigeon
the poor people having to watch this
episode they're like they are stuck
on these flying animals [ __ ] right
yeah uh after a bald eagle literally
took my wife and she divorced me
i have never been the same yeah you try
paying alimony to a woman
with a bald eagle thank you tommy for
going through all of these
these ridiculous wacky antidotes i
didn't know half of them existed
also i'm not surprised that the us did a
lot of weird stuff but
we're going to our sponsors we all shop
online and we've all seen that promo
code field thomas at the checkout and
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one
and finds it for your cart honey
supports 30 000 stores online from tech
and gaming products to popular fashion
brands and even food delivery
when you check out the honey bun drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop
honey recently saved off-screen
producers at cuddleston
zh big daddy z 15 on some exercise
equipment
but he didn't tell me what exercise
i bet it's a bowflex yeah exactly
he could crack a watermelon guys i bet
you could also be built different
if you buy these exercise these exercise
equipment with these coupons honey has
found
it's over 17 million members over 2
billion dollars in savings
2 billion that's almost more than the
pigeon thing that we did
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid in supporting this
podcast
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
bigquestion that's join honey.com
that's the government has secret weapons
in french for all you jabroni's that
aren't using babel yet
the number one selling language learning
app my kids love it and i don't even
have kids
lots of us have new year's goals to
learn a new language maybe lose a little
weight and i'm all out of weight loss
so it's time to learn a new language and
babel has made the whole process
addictively fun
and easy with bite-sized lessons that
you can actually use in the real world
babbles 15-minute lessons are the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go
pop in the ear buds while you're making
dinner or taking the dog for a walk like
i do
unlike the infamous language classes you
took in high school thanks a lot
senorita roberta
she failed me i don't remember a lick of
spanish she sucked
just kidding i'm like the infamous
language classes you took in high school
which were real snoozefests
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversations in
mind
things you'll get to use in everyday
life
like will you go home with me you go
home with me now
drinks then we go home from bar together
you can learn to say that in any
language
babble lessons were created by over 100
language experts
and their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish
french italian german vulcan klingon
you can't learn those and if you do
learn those you got a problem
okay start your new language learning
journey today with babel
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
f-r-e-e
that's free that's great in any language
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
big question
that's b a b b e l dot com
code big question for an extra three
months for free
babble language for life i forget how
much you make me cry every time
literally you guys
anytime i'm on anything with tommy i
start i like i
laugh so hard i cry i can't
stop crying and i already don't have my
glasses on so i can't read as
is just making it worse okay you guys
now we gotta answer some bite-sized
questions
uh yes let's get to the bite size
questions but first things first i want
to acknowledge the tremendous amount of
boobs what i have on my t-shirt
i take ownership of it i i identify it
you cannot call it out in the comments
you cannot make fun of me i take
ownership of it now
this is my sweat i'm sorry about it
let's do a bite-sized question
what was the relationship between shield
and the u.s government
what about sword that was from mr
cheesecake on discord ooh i love a good
cheesecake
oh my god i can't stand cheesecake but i
i'm
i love this question not you cheesecake
you're great so to answer this
the nature of most by organizations is
it's obviously very complicated
in the mcu shield is overseen by the
world security council a group of world
leaders from different countries
who we've seen most prominently in
avengers and winter soldier
that was the group that hydra aj
alexander pierce was running they're
similar to the un security council with
its five permanent members of the us uk
france russia china it's not explicitly
stated
where the world security council members
are from but the actors who play them
are from new zealand sri lanka uk
singapore the us
big representation from british colonies
the events of the mcu phase one
led to the wsc expanding the budget and
reach of shield with project insight
this parallels the creation of the
expansion of the department of homeland
security
in the us after the 9 11 terrorist
attacks it's a weird connection between
the two agencies is that um the
department of homeland security
has a program called operation shield
though it's mostly about parking lots of
law enforcement vehicles outside of
potential terrorism targets as a
deterrent it's basically
using tanks as scarecrows for terrorists
which
it works i think actual scarecrows would
work better uh if shield
if shield and sword were treated like
the other us intelligence agencies
they'd be treated like the other 17 us
intelligence agencies they all report to
the director of national intelligence
who gives daily briefings to the
president
there are some you've heard of like the
cia and the fbi but also there's the dia
inr and usaf isr like
the last one might be for an esports
league we just don't know
we we don't know these are the
researchers notes
someone in the comments is like i know
exactly what's that for and if you say
league of legends i'm going to kick your
butt
i play league of legends so i'm allowed
to say that but i'm not toxic
and that's if it were primarily a
us-based agency if there were more like
the u.n with international control
things would be even messier the u.n
security council basically did nothing
for the entire length of the cold war
because the u.s and its allies didn't
get along with china and russia
if you recall could they set those
differences aside to fight scrolls
it depends i feel like with scrolls is a
different story we probably would
kind of bow down immediately we do we'd
pull mars attacks
we pull mars attacks and try to get
along
[Music]
sword has some similarities admission to
the newly formed ussf
isr better known as space force boots on
the moon by 2024.
both of their directives include the
detection characterization
and targeting of adversary space
capabilities let's hope that means that
they're currently working to answer the
present question of
why is gamora so
yeah mr cheesecake though i hate
cheesecake i hope that answers your
question
on how they'd be similar good question
mr cheesecake yes
let's get it on we got another question
another bite-sized question what can
bucky's artificial arm do other than
provide additional strength
old man tripper and tom bechtold are
very curious about this on discord
[Music]
because i'll be honest i'd be a little
uncomfortable doing the thing we're all
thinking right now with an artificial
arm
anyway i started blasting but if it
grabs too tight what if it pulls too
hard
you know damn well that he can
distribute the weight as
so he's got that gorilla
i i don't know what you guys are talking
about i'm talking about plucking flowers
out of the ground so
oh my god i was that's so funny because
i was talking about
um not that
[Laughter]
okay we'll talk about what his arm
should actually be doing but
but the winter soldier's first arm was
given to him by dr zola from hydra after
becky fell off the train right it was
made of titanium and gave the winter
soldier enhanced strength beyond the
super
soldier's serum we see the titanium arm
perform several feets of strength so we
see it
rip the door off nick fury's suv catch
cap's shield and throw it back at him
block gunfire pull the stairwell like
railing off the wall to like catch his
fall catch a speeding motorcycle in the
most badass way
as far as strength against other heroes
he's able to throw cap around and stab
him with a knife pin him down
rip falcon's wing off overpower iron
man's gauntlet
and keep up with black panther in a
fight eventually being
messed up by iron man with his unibeam
uh which was a sad day for bucky i guess
after being briefly frozen in wakanda
bucky is gifted vibranium arm by
t'challa designed by the one and only
shuri
during the battle of wakanda the new
vibranium arm appears to have the same
characteristics as the original titanium
arm
with the addition of the new trash panda
gun wielding abilities
however because of the arm is made of
vibranium it is now nearly
indestructible
and vibration absorbent well we never
saw the vibration
arm redistribute kinetic energy like the
black panther suit
um there's potential that his arm does
hold that capability because it's made
by shuri
but maybe later on we'll see that it has
like other super secret capabilities and
falcons winter soldier that we just
didn't really know about
so i know that's kind of like in the air
but it probably does have it probably
can do
a lot more than just like be strong
i'm not saying it's like a gun
necessarily but i'm sure shuri was
probably like
took notes and was like i should make
this arm do more than just
rip the doors off let's give it a few
more features
but let's go to box scraps scraps box
scraps
my favorite meal of the day yes i love a
scrapbook i have 20
older brothers and they give me the box
scraps oh
no hey so it's okay i'm tough because of
them
i have one brother his name's jeremy and
he's really cool and he got me into nerd
stuff i just want to shout him out
so i have one brother his name is rob
he's not cool and i want him to go to
hell
no i'm just kidding love you robbie he's
my baby brother i love him
he's watching this he's like damn he
would never watch anything i do
i'm nervous i'm nervous only about this
one because my mom definitely was like
today
literally literally today i know that
this is gonna come out a couple days
later but on the phone
my mom was like i got on twitter to look
for your new rockstar videos and i can't
find them and i was like you don't go to
the twitter to like you go to youtube
i linked her to youtube and she was like
should i read the comments and i was
like
oh never no never i was like nah just
just watch the video so now she knows
where to find the videos
if she finds this one she'll be like you
joked about having sex with animals
there's too much
just say it's all my fault i'm a bad
influence it literally
i'm i probably i will throw you under
the bus
it's literally if i did an episode with
phillip it would be like
completely off the rails i'll just be
like yeah you know this is what happens
when you put it this is why boss needs
to be in charge because we need a dad
[Music]
exactly tommy let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question what movie
your tv show traumatized you as a child
oh so many i was a very frightened child
very scared kid but the movie
i had a wild imagination i think was
what it was
uh but the thing that really
freaked me out was uh the movie the evil
dead
uh so so my parents were really strict
about what we could watch
like not not like for any like they just
didn't want us at a young age being
exposed to like sex and violence and
stuff
so i had to go to my cousin's house to
watch anything bad
like i saw terminator there i saw
you know a bunch of r-rated mad max all
those movies
now the one that i regret seeing was
evil dead because
i could not i was scared of daylight
after that because
the the zombies or whatever possessed
souls of evil dead
they did not care they they killed in
broad daylight so i was like i don't
even feel safe being outside
in broad daylight anymore after seeing
that movie i was
scared of everything i was scared that
one of the like
demon girls was gonna come out of every
closet
that i had under my bed uh you know
in the shower everywhere so it was
that movie effed me up honestly that
reminds me
okay so i had one egg i had i already
had one in mine but when you said the
shower one
yeah i loved horror my mom loves horror
my mom loves scary movies that's like my
number one genre of films
so it didn't scare me more than it stuck
with me
the shower scene in it um
where they and i was like
i remember being like afraid to take
showers because i was like he's gonna
come out the drink
yes yeah i was like the worst my biggest
fear even to this day
is like an earthquake happening because
i'm naked in bed usually when the
earthquakes hit in california
it's like 2 a.m right so like to be dead
in the shower naked like i don't want
anyone to find me naked right
right yeah you can find me dead but just
don't find me naked as well
um i don't that's i don't want that to
be the case
they'll be naked in the shower and then
just be found like
right right exactly like there's nothing
cute about that
and um but i think my original one was
the movie 13 ghost because i was afraid
of ghost as a child
and there was one that had like a bird
cage yes and i was always i had
nightmares of someone with a bird cage
head coming in my bedroom
yep that one got me too don't do that to
me anyone
it's a good one it's a goodie um
obviously we want to hear everyone out
there what traumatized them
especially if it also is uh tommy's evil
dead
or if it's my ghost or naked shower
theory
though uh honestly if these were if this
was rogue theory i would get the gold
star for being naked and dead
oh no yes biggest fear biggest fear no
one wants to die
naked unless someone does then go ahead
then go off if you do you're definitely
from florida for sure from florida if
that's your
if that's your dream this is this is
what happened to the boss boss is dead
we got to bring her back he's dead
[ __ ] i'm not going i'm not bringing
him back
that's rude i'm not going to walk in on
him
oh so that is our box of scraps that is
our
that is oh my god this was a roller
coaster for anyone watching i
am honestly so surprised you made it to
the engine without thinking me and tommy
were just
insane this was wild i promise if i host
again i won't get this wild off the
tracks
but that is the end for big question
thank you tommy beckfold for joining me
for this episode my pleasure
uh folly tommy beck told us tommy how do
they follow you where are they
you can follow me tommy bechtold on all
platforms please
lucky you no one has that last name
everybody has my last name yeah there's
two also side note just for everybody
listening there is another jessica
clemens she's a therapist
that's been on like dr phil in a bunch
of tv shows don't at her i feel like
some of you guys have been adding her
because she messaged me
and she's she's much more famous than i
am
she has like magazines so don't message
her she is
also black so it doesn't help but
it's not me be better
look at the photos look at the pictures
look at the photo
enjoy yourself gorgeous come on
follow me lulu underscore clemens on
most things or lulu clements or you can
follow me physically here in la
please don't do that follow new rockstar
send us your big questions using the
hashtag bigquestion
subscribe to the podcast feed give us a
nice rating to review tell us if you
would ever sleep with a bat
uh and then subscribe to new rockstars
here on youtube hit that notification
like subscribe follow beep bop boop bada
bing
bada boom good night
[Applause]
[Music]
you